and i cried and i was in the bath
one scene was such a headache to film
daniel radcliffe suffered two ear
infections
filming the epic harry potter saga the
cast faced loads of challenges the
painful the awkward and the mentally
draining today we're taking a look at
the least pleasant scenes these actors
had to film in the wizarding world
which actor felt such distressed filming
they thought their heart stopped beating
because we were both nervous and we both
knew we were nervous the harry potter
actors particularly the trio of harry
braun and hermione had to film some
pretty terrifying scenes and sometimes
they even had to face real-life fears of
their own poor ron has to face his fear
of creepy crawly spiders in very
nerve-wracking situations regular
spiders are bad enough ron had to face
one that was larger than life as well
i'm really scared of spiders for the
actor there wasn't much acting being
done during these scenes the only false
note would have been any sense of calm
rupert grint has more in common with ron
than fiery red hair both struggle with
arachnophobia an intense fear of spiders
so i didn't know really what to expect
filming these scary scenes was a total
nightmare for grant we can't imagine he
watches those scenes back too often it's
absolutely terrifying looking back at
the earlier harry potter films in
particular the very first one can be a
very frustrating experience for emma
watson the actress hated the way her
hair was styled throughout the filming
of the first movie and thinks it looks
awful the puffiness and mess of the hair
weren't natural to the actress at all
and being so young she really wasn't a
fan of the unfortunate look
the hermione actress never felt great
while she was filming in her scene since
she was feeling self-conscious due to
the annoying and geeky hair it's not
easy
i thought it would be so much easier i
thought it'd be when harry ron and
hermione escape through the sky from
gringotts on top of a dragon it seems
like there couldn't be any better
feeling in the world
shortly after the fact when they get
dropped into a lake
well this wasn't a scene that had the
actors feeling particularly good since
later in the movie the actors have to
change they weren't able to wear any
layers underneath their clothing to keep
warm after plunging into a frigid lake
the filming for this scene took place
deep in the winter months we're talking
january february
so the water was unbearably freezing to
make it that much worse the water in the
lake couldn't be heated at all either so
the actors had to struggle trying to
perform and breathe normally in these
trying conditions for watson it was one
of the absolute worst experiences she
had filming rupert grint actually
struggled so much at one point he was
terrified because he felt as if his
heart had stopped beating
if anything he feels more dangerous just
watching harry potter and the goblet of
fire is an intense experience
we absolutely feel for the actors who
had to deal with rough weather daring
stunts and extremely emotional scenes
for radcliffe the worst scenes to film
for the fourth installment were the ones
underwater as part of the triwizard
tournament to prepare for these daring
scenes radcliffe had to undergo intense
diving lessons to make sure he could
perform what was needed as safely as
possible the stress didn't end there
though
unfortunately it took a full six weeks
of torture to finally capture all the
footage that was needed for the movie in
total radcliffe dealt with a full 41
hours underwater filming that amount of
time in combination with the freezing
temperatures were pretty rough on the
actor physically radcliffe wound up
suffering two bad ear infections as a
result of the rough filming conditions a
bit frustrating was the fact that
communication is obviously quite
difficult while daniel radcliffe played
a total quidditch star he wasn't such a
fan of shooting any of the high-flying
scenes throughout the films sure the
novelty was cool at first which 10 year
old wouldn't want to pretend to fly on a
broomstick unfortunately it wasn't all
it was cracked up to be and there were
some serious downsides to sitting on
brooms for hours at a time
including nun buns
radcliffe was often in pain while
filming and dreaded every time he had to
mount his broom which wasn't much more
than that
a hard broom
instead of feeling like they were on top
of the world the quidditch players
resented sitting on the uncomfortable
and impractical devices one might think
looking back could bring some sense of
fondness or longing to have another go
at it but according to radcliffe it's
not something i'd rush back to just
because you made the team last year does
not guarantee you a spot this year is
that clear bonnie wright got to show off
some amazing skills when dumbledore's
army was hard at work in the room of
requirement while the actress enjoyed
performing those scenes the experience
of filming them wasn't her favorite
because of the magical room itself
wright felt extremely claustrophobic in
the space which was only made worse by
the fact that some scenes saw tons of
people needing to be in the same room at
the same time for the actress the
crowding and anxiety became too much to
handle and she was left feeling totally
hysterical the memories are too strong i
think for all of us the room of
requirement really wasn't all it was
cracked up to be
bonnie wright's on-screen older twin
brothers james and oliver phelps hated
having to film scenes on the dreaded set
not because it was too overcrowded but
because they got way too hot the actors
claimed the set was often extremely warm
and combined with the warm sweaters they
had to wear the twins overheated while
filming
the results may look brilliant but in
reality the set was a sweaty nightmare
and the actors hated having to do it
even though the content was pretty
incredible well done everyone great
great work we all love to hate dolores
umbridge and while the actress plays the
cruel and vicious woman extremely
convincingly the performance came at a
cost imelda staunton loved working on
the franchise but after filming
intensely mean scenes she didn't always
feel very good one scene in particular
put her over the edge
the actress was left feeling really
awful for a couple of days after filming
this scene with the most painful line
session we've ever seen
you deserve to be punished it was a
really disturbing moment for staunton
when she realized people could be
capable of such vile behavior for some
actors filming deeply cruel and vicious
content can be seriously tough mentally
because she's
quite hard bonnie wright of course had
to lock lips with daniel radcliffe but
when it came to filming their kissing
scenes in particular their first in the
sixth film wright felt a lot of
uncomfortable pressure performing what
was meant to be a pretty significant
moment combine that with the awkwardness
of kissing someone who's more like
family in front of a crowd of people who
are filming your every move let's just
say kissing harry unfortunately wasn't
the most fun scene for the actress to
film just like any other scene that
you're filming so acting legend day
maggie smith had her fair share of
difficult experiences behind the scenes
on the harry potter set
the actress had to endure acting and
sitting in huge heavy costumes heavy
hats were the cherry on top of the
annoying experience
what made it all worse is that sometimes
she'd prepare to film a scene in full
costume hair and makeup but they
wouldn't get to her so all that duress
was for nothing not to mention the fact
that smith also underwent cancer
treatments while filming some of the
movies
talk about a trooper no one can mess
with mcgonagall is it's magic
adolescence is tough for any teenager
but poor matthew lewis had to deal with
being a teenager and made to look
supremely awkward and nerdy various
movies saw lewis in a fat suit false
teeth and bits of plastic behind his
ears to make them stick out being on set
and filming made the actor very
self-conscious
particularly once he was a bit older and
was more attuned to the fact that there
were lots of girls on set who only ever
saw him as nerdy neville it was horrible
while we gushed watching hermione and
ron finally kiss the two actors weren't
feeling nearly as good about the whole
situation the pair of course have a
sibling-like relationship having grown
up together so performing this intimate
and passionate kiss in front of loads of
people who they'd also known for years
was a nightmare
that wasn't the only awkward kiss though
watson and radcliffe had to share a
steamy smooch as well which was made
even worse to film by the presence of
rupert grint the actor's laughter didn't
last for long though since it was so
distracting watson actually had grint
kicked off of the set
helen and bonham carter gives an
extraordinary performance as the evil
bellatrix but when she was on set things
sometimes went a bit too far leaving the
actress with some regrettable memories
bonham carter wound up badly injuring
her co-star matthew lewis when she
perforated his eardrum during a scene
leaving him with internal bleeding while
the scene looks great in the movie it
wasn't so fun for the actress to film we
can't imagine it was matthew lewis's
favorite either everyone had their
different styles of one fighting
could there be anything more chilling
than an embrace from he who shall not be
named
tom felton was totally taken off guard
by this improvised move from voldemort
actor ray fines which left him feeling
really uncomfortable the whole scene had
felt in on edge confused and a little
terrified by the creepy hug
well done
while the banquet scenes in the first
film looked regal and decadent filming
them was far from pleasant for the
actors if we could smell what was on
film audiences would have been running
out of the theater because the food
being filmed had been rotting for days
as the days went on shooting these
scenes became nauseating for the actors
who had to deal with the stench of food
going bad only made worse by being under
hot lights for hours on end i'll say one
two three in action the food appears who
knew filming such a beloved series could
have been so difficult for the actors
knowing just how big a struggle these
scenes were for the performers in real
life totally changes our perspective of
their performances with such pros it's
no surprise they were so often able to
act through their discomfort
which scene sounded toughest to you